so with all that warm welcome for our
speaker hi everyone
Thank You Jared for having me I think so
does that sound okay give me here can
you hear me okay that one the other one
the other one was Green
all right good good sorry okay can
everyone hear is that okay okay so the
title of my talk today is simulating a
universe in Thai diverse using art to
generate in statistical simulations and
I've envisioned this talk to be for a
person that maybe knows a lot about Thai
diverse but doesn't know how to run
simulations using the Thai reverse or
maybe a person that knows a lot about
simulations but wants to try them out in
Thai rivers so I'm a data scientist a
broom and broom is an e-commerce company
that buys use cars sends them to this
huge factory and fix them and then we
list them on our website rom-com and so
if you go on the website you can order
the cars to be delivered to your house
and so we have tons of data analytics
and data science needs and we do
simulations pretty often and so in this
talk what I would like to cover is
reasons why simulations are useful at
all and then I'm going to cover some of
the basics of generating random data in
our and how do you integrate that random
data in using the player and the Thai
rivers and that kind of sets up the
framework of how to run a simulation and
I will go on on three examples the for
example is to run a simulation of a
regression model and with that set up we
can do a power calculation in for an a/b
test and my last example is going to be
to generate random data in order to
create art and so in this talk I'm going
to focus in the packages the player
Khidr / and ggplot2
there's probably other ways to do
simulations even with these tools other
than the one I'm going to present here
and there's other ways that you can run
simulations without these tools so that
you can use ver base R and use
combinations of nested for-loops you can
use the drake package which i found
quite useful lately and you can also use
a specific packages for simulation so
there's packages to simulate random
missing data or survival data but
there's others other ways you can do
this as well so why would you want to do
a simulation at all so in this talk I'm
going to focus her zone data science
educational purposes and what I mean by
that is sometimes you learn a new method
a machine learning method or a new
statistical model and you are a little
bit confused about how it works so I
always find it really useful to simulate
a lot of data and just train your model
or run your method on that data and as
you change the sample size or the number
of variables or correlation among
variables you get a lot of insight on
how your metal works on in which
situations a model will work best so
that's really useful also you can always
use a simulation to do a power
calculation if you're doing a study
design for an a/b test and also you can
have some fun and make some art not that
power calculations are not found other
reasons are that at room we use it to
understand business processes so we
might simulate data of cars that are
coming into a factory and we simulate
data on how long they're going to take
to get fixed and then how long they take
to be delivered to a customer in that
way we can find out about bottlenecks in
our system another reason is to generate
useful fake data and recently I was
working with a Dana analyst she needed
to create this dashboard that takes as
input some data generated by our model
but the model is going to be in
production like a month from now but
that dashboard we will wanted to have it
ready now
so I created its fake data of hub the
data will look like and she was able to
create the dashboard you know on time
before we launch the model to production
and there's other ways there's other
reasons why you would want to simulate
data
so how do you simulate data in our so
some of the basics are these functions
that start with R and I guess they mean
random and I'm going to focus on three
of them so the r norm function the R
plus sum function and there are binomial
function so the unknown function
simulates not randomly distributed data
with a normal distribution and the first
outcome n is the sample size of how many
data you want to simulate the mean is
just the mean of the normal distribution
and SD is the standard deviation so you
will want to use this function when you
want to generate continuous outcomes
another very useful function is the
Artois function which is for random
Poisson variables and it only has one
parameter lambda which is the mean but
as well as its variance and if you want
to simulate data that looks like count
outcomes this one is really useful and
another useful function is our binomial
which will simulate a binary outcome if
you set the size equal to zero and this
is really useful to simulate the a B
test because you can simulate zero once
corresponding to a random assignment on
a test and there's other functions that
you can use if you want to look at skews
positive data exponential distribution
but I won't cover those in this talk and
so how can you start using these
functions that generate random data in
in R so the first thing that you can do
is create a data frame and call that
column our sample and assign it your
random sample that comes from your
normal function in this case so this in
this column our sample it's going to
live a normally distributed data and
there's going to be 10,000 data points
in this data frame and they're going to
have a mean of 1000 and a start at a
standard deviation of 250 and then if
you are not if you are new to the Thai
rivers and these symbol over here is the
pipe which comes from the plier and what
that says is I'm going to create this
data frame and then I'm going to apply
to it these ggplot function that's going
to create a graph underneath and so to
create the graph you tell the ggplot
function
please use as your input data the our
sample my random data
and to it I'm going to add histogram
with the GM histogram function and ask
it to give me 300 beans and then I'm
going to create a vertical line to
specify the mean of the sample at 1000
with the gmv line function and I want
that line to be red and then I'm going
to add a team called line draw with this
is this beautiful black and white team
that I really like so then we see that
our data looks normal and has I mean
roughly of 1000 and you can do the same
thing with the R plus some function so
now you're our sample column contains
Poisson distributed data with a mean of
3 and if you plot again the histogram of
it we see that instead of being
continuous is that discrete integers
with mean of 3 and if you do that the
same thing with the R by Norm function
we get a 0 0 1 outcome variable and we
see because I set the probability to be
50% that we that out of the 10,000 we
get 50 roughly 5 5,000 zeroes and 5,000
ones yes so that's really cool so then
how would you incorporate these
functions in in the tidal barrage the
specificity player so the first function
that I use I found really useful for
this is this last function so the
definition of this live function says
that this function chooses the rows by
the ordinal position in the table or the
data frame so if I fit a data frame to
the slice function and a vector we want
to dream on it it will output the row
one two and three of that data frame but
then you want to do something more
elaborate and I've fit to the slice
function these repeat function what the
repeat function is going to do is going
to repeat one and two each one of them
three times so then when the slice
function reads this vector it's going to
output the rows one three times and two
three times and I can generalize that
even further and say okay repeat
function I want want to be repeated two
times but I want the number to to be
repeated three times so then when I feed
that to the slice I'm going to have the
row first row repeated one
as twice and the second one repeated
three times so what I mean this seems
all kind of boring but the reason why
this is very useful is because
simulations have a nest nested
destructed or repeated observations so
if I have a thousand simulations that I
want to be that simulation to be
repeated let's say a hundred times four
to high so that that simulation will
have a hundred observations and it saves
you most of your headache while doing
simulations because it will set up kind
of like the skeleton of the simulation
and after you've done that you can start
generating tons of data so let me go
over a simple example here so let's say
I have a simple AP test with three cars
and I want to simulate these a B test
twice so I'm going to create a data
frame that has three observations in a
column from observations I D going from
1 to 2 2 to 3 but because I have two
simulations I want to repeat these
observations twice so then I use the
slice function and I feed it the repeat
function to it and I said please repeat
my observation i D each of them twice so
now I've I've repeated each of my
observations twice so I have just the
behavior I wanted because I wanted them
to be up here or twice there but then
the next thing I want to do is I want to
create a sim simulation ID column and
what that column is going to keep in
there is is the indicator for that
simulation since I have two simulations
I want the Cemal ID column to be the
numbers one and two repeated each of
them three times because each of them
contain three observations and then with
the arranger statement what I'm going to
do is I'm going to arrange the the data
frame by the simulation ID and then the
observation ready and then I'm going to
with the Select statement I'm going to
select first the simulation ID and then
the observation ID and so the resulting
data frame is two simulations each one
of them containing three observations
okay so that kind of sets up the
skeleton of your simulation but now I
want to create fake random data so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to add
these
- the mutate statement which is this
play song bar over here and what that
does is going to call the our Poisson
variable and is going to generate data
with a Poisson distribution with a mean
of 10 and I'm going to call this deep
liar function which is the end in
parentheses and what that says is tells
a pass on the our Poisson function that
it wants as many random data as there
are some rows in the data frame and then
the other other thing that I'm going to
do in addition is I'm going to rename my
variables so I'm going to call opps ID
I'm going to rename it as car ID and
then the Poisson variable I'm going to
call it online views so then I have a
data set that contains two simulations
on three cars and they're on live views
that they get on a daily basis you know
on live rooms rooms website let's say
for example okay so that we that really
super simple example what we've done is
simulated two simulations but now what
we're going to do is going to create a
thousand simulations and on each of
those we are going to run a regression
model so we're going to end up with a
thousand regression models and then
we're going to plot each of their
coefficients for price in them and we're
going to see a hist histogram of the
distribution of these coefficients that
come from a thousand models so to do
that the first thing is to simulate a
linear model and what you need to do is
simulate a set of independent variables
and once you've done that you need to
define a mean as a linear function of
those independent variables and once
you've done that you need to simulate
your outcome as a normal distribution
with that define me and then what we'll
do with the with the tie rivers is we're
going to simulate data on line number of
views and we're going to run the
regression we don't learn views as
outcome and we're going to look the
distribution of the effect of price on
views so this is the same data frame
I'll show you in the previous chunk I've
just added like four more lines so the
first line is this line price over here
and what
the new column price is going to be a
random sample from a Poisson
distribution with me in 15 and then what
I'm going to do as well as create a
column called miles we has a
distribution poisson with mean 25 so I'm
assuming price having Hamming 15 or 15
million and 25 miles being also a
thousand and then I'm going to create a
new column called num mean number of
views and that is going to say okay all
of my cars have 200 views on average on
my website but every time I price or my
mileage increases by a thousand my mind
my average number of you decreases by
two so this is what the mean number of
views means and then I'm going to create
the actual outcome which is the number
of views and that's going to have a
normal distribution with the mean that
you've defined in the previous line that
depends both on price and miles and I'm
going to assign it a standard deviation
of 20 okay so and at the end with the
head 6 statement that's going to display
the first six observations of this data
frame and so now we have a simulation I
do ID so I have two simulations three
cars per simulation but each car gets a
prize I'm mileage mean number of views
but also the actual number of views that
they gone on the website so you have
your first sort of data frame with a
bunch of simoleons using them so now
what we want to go is apply a linear
model to each of these simulations I did
but going forward I'm going to have a
thousand simulation IDs that correspond
to a thousand simulations and I want to
run on each one of those one model so to
do that I'm going to use the nest
function from tidy R and what that nest
function does is that it groups the data
frame it separates them into different
data frames each for one simulation
radio so it group them in separate data
frames for each simulation and then I'm
going to use the map function from per
package and run a linear model
separately on each of these data frames
and then finally once I
retrieve the coefficient for the model
that I'm interested in I'm going to put
everything back together in one and one
data frame with the unless some tidy are
yes I think it was fine yeah yeah I mean
I ran a simulation we like 200 and 200
Andy I like simulations tend to be as
low but I think it's more for study
designed so you wouldn't have to you
wouldn't want to do this sort of thing
like in production where where where I
mean I don't I don't see the value of
maybe there's possibly a way yes
yeah so I focused more on like the
easiness to do the simulation other than
the fastest so yeah it can get pretty
complicated to run a simulation right in
my opinion okay so how do you apply the
this Ness function once you've run this
data frame that I showed before so the
first thing that you need to do is group
your data frame with a group by function
and you group it by simulation ID and
that you need as a requirement to apply
your nest function next and so then you
apply your nest function and what we're
going to do is going to save it in this
similar nested object which is our
nested data frame and so what does this
the nested data frame look like so if we
apply the names function to it it has a
vector of simulation IDs which each idea
of the 1,000 simulations and a data
object we contains a thousand data
frames one for each simulation and if
you look at the data element of the
nested data frame and the first element
there we get a data frame with our first
simulation it has the car data the price
data the mileage and the number of views
okay but now we want to run a simulation
in each of those data frames so the
first thing is that we need to define a
function that runs a linear model so the
first function takes as input a data
frame and it's going to create it's
going to run a linear model with the
number of users outcome and prizing
mileage as dependent variables and we're
going to call that function num views
model and then I'm going to create a
second function that takes that input a
model and then it's going to output the
coefficient of price and so what that
function is going to do is going to look
into the coefficients of the model and
look at the second coefficient because
the first coefficient is the intercept
and it's going to wrap it around as
numeric because there are some names
that come with it I want to get rid of
them
and I'm going to call this function the
function on number of views price
coefficient and so to apply it to all my
data frames
having nested I need to use the map
function from pair so what / does is
transforms the input by applying a
function to each element and returning a
vector of the same length as the input
so our input is going to be a thousand
data frames and I'm going to output a
thousand linear models and later I'm
going to fit it a thousand linear models
and I'm going to get back a thousand
coefficients so how do you do that so
it's pretty simple I just start with my
nested data frame first and then I
applied the mutator statement to it and
then we team mutate I'm going to use the
map function and I'm going to tell the
map function okay look in the data
elements of these nested data frame and
apply to each element the number of
views model and then save it back in -
the data frame has an element called
model and was our brawndo's model I'm
going to apply the map function again
and apply it to the model element of it
and I'm going to - each model apply the
function number of use price coefficient
which is going to return my coefficient
or price and I'm going to save it in
this element price coefficient okay so
how does this look like once we've run
these models so now we see that there's
an element model living in this data
frame and if we look at the first
element there we can verify that there's
a model that lives there that has a
number of views as outcome it has an
intercept a price and my Lascaux miles
coefficient and then if we look in the
price cough go F element of this nested
data frame we see that we get the
coefficient of price they live in the in
the model section of the nested data
frame so now these all these results are
separated in kind of like thousand
different locations in this vector so to
put them back together into one data
frame we use The Awl NASA so nesting
creates a list column of data frames but
on a nest and flats flattens it back
into a regular column so to get it back
into a data frame and so we feed the
unless function the nested data frame so
that's the first element and then we ask
them please return the price
efficient part of it and then we're
going to select the simulation ID column
and the price coefficient column and
then we're going to save it in these new
objects which is going to be a data
frame and it will inspect in it we see
that effectively we we get one column
with the simulation ID and one
coefficient per simulation so you've a
grenade all your coefficients of your
1000 models into one data frame and then
if you decide to plot these data with
the coefficients you tell GG plot please
give me please take as input data the
price coefficients and then run a
histogram and then run the team that I
like and so what we see here is that all
the 1000 coefficients follow roughly a
normal distribution and that the mean is
near minus two so like if you are taking
a linear models class you might know
that like a model is on bias and then
you like not sure what that means but
then if you plot this distribution what
you can see is that actually the on
average the model is correct and the
distribution of the coefficient follows
a normal distribution which you might
have read in a textbook or in your class
as well and then if you want to
summarize this whole data you can take
the data frame with the coefficients and
you can ungroup them because before they
were grouped and you can use the
summarized function to create these this
summary of the mean the mean of the
coefficient and to do that you just
apprise the mean function to the price
curve column and as well you can
calculate the standard deviation by
applying the standard deviation function
on the price coefficient and why we see
what we see is that the mean of the all
the coefficients it's very close to the
actual value of how we generated the
data and it but it has some variability
around it because we have a standard
deviation yeah so so that kind of like
you can look into how the linear model
performs and so after you've done that
you can sort of apply this methodology
for to do a power calculation and an a/b
test
so kind of like a silly example on
brooms website we may have a random
subset of cars to have a certain
resolution of the under pictures and
some other cars that randomly got a
better resolution of the picture it's
kind of like not very intelligent
experiment that you can want to see all
the cars that have a higher resolution
picture do they get more views on them
so two people end up clicking on them
more and seeing them so so what exactly
so that the a B test I want to run and
so what's a power calculation while
doing an a/b test so what you want to do
is figure out what the sample size that
you need for your a B test and given
certain inputs on the inputs are going
to be the minimal difference that you're
interested in so I might be interested
on my cars that have a higher resolution
pictures to have on average ten more
views per week and everything below that
maybe I'm not interested at all so this
is the minimum effect that I'm
interested you to see the if the
pictures work and then another thing
that I need to fix is the type 1 error
so I might say it my type 1 error is at
5% so I don't want to make that that's
what I've established before and then
another thing that I need to tell the
simulation is I want a power of at least
90% so that's my ability to detect the
effect there plus some assumptions about
the data and so sometimes when you when
you want to run this test you might
spend a lot of time reading papers or
textbooks and find a formula that allows
you to calculate the sample size that
the thing is that you don't you don't
need a formula you can always just run a
simulation and in many cases they might
not be up if your study or your model is
too complicated they might not X is the
formula so you can all resort to do a
simulation so sometimes you run
complicated hierarchical mixed models
you can run a simulation to calculate
that and so the way you do it is you you
simulate the data with the assumption
in the inputs and you do this thousands
of times and then you get a p-value of
your tests and then you calculate the
proportion of times the p-value is less
than the type 1 error rate and that
basically is your power so no need for
any formula and then if you're given
sample size doesn't reach that power
then you can keep increasing your your
sample size entities until you reach the
power that you want so that's what we're
going to do with what I've shown you so
far and kind of following that example
on rom-com web site but I'm going to
also do two things I'm going to run one
linear model that's going to have a
p-value for the effect of treatment and
I'm going to have a second model where
I'm going to adjust for variables or
covariance and which are going to be the
miles and the price of the car and I'm
going to see if that approach is more
powerful that only including the
treatment in the in the linear model and
so some of my assumptions are going to
be that the number of views is normally
distributed and the number of views
depends linearly on price and mileage of
the car and then the inputs is that the
newly I have an a/b test for a new
layout or resolution of the pictures on
the cars and that resolution increased
the average number of views by 10 views
weekly and I'm going to start with a
sample size of 100 okay so now and then
when I run the simulation the power is
going to be the Y and so the output is
going to be the power given this set up
and we're going to see we reach the 90%
power that we want and so this is the
same courage chunko that i show you
before but I've added two-to-one lining
and a change to a previous one so the
first line is a treatment variable which
is he calls the our binomial function
and it generates a zero one outcome that
kind of like your randomized treatment
assignment and each one of them has a
50% probability and then what you're
going to do is go to your mean number of
views and you're going to make a change
to what you had previously which is this
plus 10 times the treatment so what that
means is on average a car that's on the
treat
he's going to have ten more number of
views on average on a given week and
then the rest is the same then you
generate your number of views variable
as a normally distributed random
variable yes so then these the outcome
that you get is the same days
buffering we saw before but now you we
have a treatment column with a random
assignment of zero and ones for the
treatment and now what I'm going to do
is create three functions so the first
two functions is going to build a model
that explains the number of use based on
treatment and another one that does the
same thing but adjusts for price as well
as as well as mileage and then the third
one is a function that's going to
recover the p-value for the treatment in
fact in each model so the first model is
going to be the number of use model
without adjustment and the other one is
going to be weight assessment and then
the function is going to the last
function is the treatment p-value that's
going to look into the model apply the
summary function to it then look into
the coefficient and it's going to look
at the second row for the treatment
effect and then the four column for the
for the p-value and so then we save our
data frame in this seem a B data frame
and then we're going to do the same
thing with it before where we're going
to apply apply a group by statement and
we're going to group the data by
simulation ID and then we're going to
nest the data so now we're separated the
data furring into a thousand different
data frames and I'm going to use the
mutator statement which is going to call
the map function and the map function is
going to say okay look at my data and
build a model for the number of views
without the adjustment they do so also
for the model with the adjustment and
then the map function is going to be
called again and we're going to feed the
model without the adjustment and this is
going to output the p-values for the
treatment effect and it's going to do
the same thing for the models with
adjustment so now if we look into the
word lives inside the
simulation might be nested object we
have a ID for simulation we have the
data and we have the model without model
with a jasmine and the p-values from
each of those models and so if we see Y
lives in here so we can see that there's
a model without and if we look at the
first element of it and the coefficients
we see that there's an intercept in a
treatment and then if we look at the
element that says model wait for the
models with adjustment and we look at
the coefficients we see that we get an
intercept a treatment bed as well as a
coefficient for price and miles and so
we have effectively created two set of
1000 models and then we see as well that
the p-values live in these nets that
there's nested data frame as well
so now we can unless the this nested
data frame again by applying the unmask
and we tell the onus function please
give me the p-values and we say them in
a data frame that contains only the
p-values without the adjustment as well
as another they referring with the
adjustment and then what we can do is
calculate the power of our test using
the model only with the treatment and to
do that we look at the data frame with
the p-values and we can apply the
summarized function and then we use the
min function to the p-values and what
this function does is it calculates the
proportion of p values that are less
than 5% and then we we save it in this
column called power with adjustment and
we see that our power is sixty seven
point five percent and yes so then
you've calculated your power fasting
coding time but not in running time and
and then here we get the power of the of
the model without the adjustments and we
see that the the power is a little bit
lower than the previous model so it's 56
percent so the the conclusion of this of
these code that we run is that with our
sample size of 100 you don't get enough
power to get to 90 but you're better off
with the model
that does the adjustment of the
covariates so if you need to run a
different power calculation with any
sort of model or any sort of test you
can just change this code and feed it a
function that runs your tests to your
particular data and you can calculate
power again okay so that's kind of like
the usefulness of of simulations but if
we want to create some art you can also
use random data to do so so I stumbled
into this gallery while I was walking in
New York City and I saw this piece by
Manfred Moore and it kind of has this
random pattern of lines around it and I
thought oh this looks like it could be
simulated and I was thinking it has a
hierarchical structure where this grid
of squares so within these are their
squares they live inside of it and
inside a square
there's a line that lives inside of it
and inside the line there's a dot
there's many dots on it insiders who
kind of had the hierarchy hierarchy of a
simulation so I said if I can simulate
one square then I can simulate this
whole piece of art so I went and it
started to simulate the one square so
the first thing I did was okay I know I
think this is actually another square
but I think it's more of a rectangle
that's on the along the x-axis is of
length 10 and along the y-axis is a
level 5 and I'm going to create these
dots data frame that contains the
initial dot on that line is starting
from the left and so the first thing I
did is I call a data frame function and
I'll I fit it I call this column called
number of lines that I ran one random
draw from a Poisson distribution and
with mean 10 and I added a plus 1 here
because sometimes you can get a zero so
I want at least one line to live in this
square and then that gives me the number
of lines and so right now that they
referring has only one row but then I
use the splice function and say ok
repeat all my rows as as many lines as I
have in
and Lines columns so if I drew seven
lines than these data frame is going to
be repeated seven times and then I'm
going to create a mutator statement and
the first line generates an ID for each
line and the line X star variable is the
start of the first point on the x-axis
and that's a sample draw from a number
from two to nine so on the x-axis and on
the y-axis as well I draw a sample from
a number from one to five so to have a
start on the y-axis and I also have a
line length which I draw from a random
discrete uniform between 1 and 3 and a
line thickness which is also random
between 1 and 5 and then I call the
splice function again and I say because
each line has a length I need this to be
further expand so that each line gets
repeated as as as its length so that
kind of gives me the the the these dots
dataframe and we see the first line has
a start on the x axis and I start on the
y axis and it has a line length so it's
just then 1 so it's just 1 dot that for
the second line it has length 2 and that
the the right not only had the start of
the line but I don't have the the how
the line moves so that's what I'm going
to do next so I'm going to create these
lines data frame that is going to add to
these initial points so that the line
has a movement so the first thing that
I'm going to do is group by the line ID
and so what that does is the next
mutated statement operates only at the
line ID level and so the first thing as
I create this x axis line which tells me
where my line aids in the x-axis and
that for that I take the beginning dot
and I just add a vector of going from 0
to its length so it's just moving one
step every time and then on the y-axis
steps the line is going to move up and
down from its beginning and I accomplish
that by doing a random draw from vector
of minus 1 and 1 and then I add that
vector to the
to the beginning of the line on the
x-axis so if the line is started our
tree then you can move up to four tree
or state and move up and down and then
at the end I own group and I saved these
data furring in these lines data frame
and that's all I need to do and that
basically generate that and tired almost
entire that art so to apply a ggplot way
that I tell ggplot okay use my x-axis
line and my y-axis lines are the
coordinates of my points and and uses
group the line ID because each one each
line is going to be its own line and
each line gets a size and I want
everything to be color black and then
I'm going to call the genome line
function but because I've used the group
statement previously it's going to build
each line a different line for each line
ID and then I call this gem age line
function which is going to generate five
different horizontal lines that are
going to give the look of the each
square and so if you plot this it kind
of looks like this kind of weird pattern
over here and so that's kind of like
your square and so but I want to
simulate these multiple times over a
grid of squares so the only minor change
dynamic to my code is now I define
parameters as n numbers of squares and I
want a grid that's 20 by 20 and then
what I'm going to start is I'm going to
start with a data frame that halves
column that squares IDs which is ID is
going from 1 up to 20 by 20 so for the
total number of squares but then
everything else is very similar so now I
have a mutator statement that is going
to give me per square a random number of
lines that are going to live there so
each square is going to care get a
random subset of lines but then
everything else is pretty similar so
this this chunk was a little bit more
generous that whole piece of art and
then you can generate the same ggplot as
you saw before but over a grid and you
can only get this frame that it's kind
of like a very similar reproduction of
what malphur did which everybody was
really cool that I thought it will take
me much
and something I forgot to mention is
that malphur he did is working the ABS
or seventies using Fortran so they were
like pages and pages of Fortran code to
generate this and but we with the tie
rivers II was you know a couple of
chunks of code plus a chunk of ggplot
and you get this and then so my my boss
director of the design has this machine
that's called the XY plotter and so you
can feed it
these PNG is that you've saved from our
and it will like draw it like little by
little with these pencil and you just
give it a random pen you can even give
it a pencil as well it will draw things
and so then you know my boss framer that
was really nice and so now we have these
art I run the office for a change
instead of a bunch of cars around so and
yes so that's like you can all be
artists with the tidy version ggplot
yeah so that's it thank you and I want
to say special thanks to Ludmila yonder
my wife because she listened to this
talk like many times and also my boss
Jeff because he printed the art and
brought it to the office today yeah
thank you
[Applause]
Thank You captain Emiquon his lights I
went on our studio new file our markdown
and I think is I was lights HTML
presentation and just went from there
yeah I mean what else did I do you thing
I looked up all how do you include an
image and there's an then there's an 8
neither comment to add an image and then
just figure out how to sometimes show
codes but not run it so I think that
once I forgot it's a volley calls falls
yeah I think so yeah that doesn't run it
and if you want to run it they don't
show the code you say echo equals false
in the new trunk yeah super easy yeah
yeah that's thank you thank you thank
you for asking that that's usually when
I've done it it does yeah I don't know
if there's a caveat there I don't think
so and so thank you for asking this so
like for people that are new to doing
simulations or generating random data in
our so if you run this code and then you
run it again it's going to look
different so if you want the random
numbers to be the same you you use this
function that C dot sort of said dot C
then put an integer in there and that
kind of sets the start of your random
generating machine because they're
they're actually called pseudo random
numbers because you can set up this
number in the seed and you'll get the
same set of numbers that's all I will
say about that for now
thank you oops oh that's a good point
No
okay let me let me say that so like I
the way I've sort of learned is when I'm
trying to apply a method or construct
something I tried to see how the data
has arrived to me and kind of write down
that process may being a piece of paper
make a little graph and and if you have
that correct you cannot get a general
idea of how you can go about simulating
the data yeah but I mean there's papers
like if you look in the literature
there's papers on simulations for power
calculations I think that would be the
easiest thing to start because there
they sometimes tell you don't do this do
that so if you do that you might get
something really fast yeah yeah sure
so you you want to similar ordinal data
that is correlated to a continuous
outcome and is your ordinal data the
outcome itself or or is just a variable
or it's just like it's some data that
you have
Wow yeah I mean there's a couple there's
a couple of things you could do so the
the thing that you could do I mean is
maybe it's a little convoluted but you
can have like a latent variable that you
simulate as being continuous and that
your continuous outcome that you're
interested in it depends on that
continues the latent variable somehow so
maybe you have a normal distribution and
you simulate that as being your latent
variable plus another normal
distribution okay and then you can do
kind of for your ordinal random variable
you can make it so that the
probabilities are generated based on
that latent variable so you've kind of
create a dependency between those two
that's one of the standard ways to do it
yeah that I can give you I can give you
more details I probably need to explain
a little bit more I just want to yeah
yeah yeah but there's definitely ways
that you can do this
yeah yeah so yeah so something that you
can do in your let's say you're doing a
power calculation that you had you have
data while you're trying to run your
tests on so you have idea what the
distributions look like so you could do
something like that to where you have
your random data actually comes from
data that exists but you may run out
like a bootstrap sample from it and then
run your a pieces so that's something
that you can do too as well and probably
matches better the distribution of the
actual data that you've seen yeah I kind
of wanted to include that in this term
but it's just too much information
we use it were
simulation
we haven't really done dat the way we've
used simulation before is more like a
study design planning like you would you
have a new methodology in you you create
new fake data and you see okay if I have
these data or this let's say my data
it's data on cars so I say okay if I
applied this method I saved money on how
I fix my cars betting if I apply the the
previous method on like industrial metal
I maybe lose money so that kind of gives
me an idea or if my new method is going
to work
so kind of decision making and study
planning but is not so much as compared
to what's in production because I guess
the next step to that would be okay I'm
going to run an actual a/b test and
that's what actually confirms to me if
this thing works or not
yeah does that kind of answer your
question yeah so yeah yes so so right
now we were thinking about changing like
a different like how we fix our cars and
there's some like decision tree of how
we fix our cars and so there's an all
method that we know and we have a new
method and we were kind of doing what
the previous person has is like do you
use path data so we use path data and we
pass it through these methods and we can
use the bootstrap to create some randoms
around it and we say okay we kept to the
previous method we will have fixed our
cars annual cost us this much but if we
use the new method maybe we save money
right so that kind of and we use the the
random as in view from the bootstrap of
our previous historical data yeah does
that kind of make sense yes some
sometimes sometimes yeah that this was
actually an ask from high up so that was
yeah
right house
thank you
[Applause]